[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a cast of come from away the
Broadway musical tells the story of a
small town in Newfoundland Canada
airline passengers were offered safe
harbor and Gander after planes were
grounded there on September 11th 2001
the show recently won a Drama Desk Award
for Best Musical it's it's up for seven
Tony Awards this Sunday night CBS's
Sunday mornings Mo Rocca introduces us
to the cast members and the real-life
pilot who's depicted on the stage and
whatever is in between it's being called
Broadway's surprise hit of the season in
the window and again as always I now
come from away is playing to
standing-room-only crowds more and more
people keep coming and you look
surprised and grateful and you all have
seen your beaming but what is what is
drawing people I think people are coming
here repeatedly to heal yes comfortable
way is less about the terrible events of
9/11 more about the kindness of
strangers through tragedy comes joy they
always say the light at the end of the
tunnel but if you really open your eyes
the light is always there they move all
your pity ladies waving from the dock to
shine that 1:12 cast members play both
Newfoundland natives
and stranded airline passengers from all
over the world for five days nearly
doubled the population of gander a town
with about 10,000 residents on the
northeast tip of North America on an
island called in Finland most characters
are a compilation of real people who the
writers interviewed for the show
they said girl shouldn't be in the
cockpit hey lady
hey baby the pilot portrayed by Tony
nominee Chen Colella however is based on
real-life airline pioneer Beverly bass
nothing is made up everything is real
and it is the way that it really
happened
the first female captain of a major
American airline and one of the pilots
diverted to Gander that day did meeting
her change your performance at all yes
absolutely um we we stopped mean look
how we're sitting right now look look at
how we're sitting like I have adopted a
lot of her mannerisms the two have
become close friends
Beverly how many times have you seen
this show well last night was 68 times
1986 the first female merican captain
I never get tired of saying so I'll say
it many more times I feel like I'm
soaring when I'm listening to her sing
what does it feel like for you
it is unbelievable she's so little
and the way she belts out that voice and
I always just take a deep breath because
I know it's gonna be beautiful
yeah I like to that hearing that you're
leaving for me my heart is racing to for
its Broadway debut the cast performed a
pair of sold-out shows at a hockey rink
in gander yes
we were cold player you to Beyonce
yourself
patrina Bromley is the one cast member
who's actually from Newfoundland I meet
the people every night who are so proud
and for me that's one of the biggest
rewards of doing this show because when
in your life is your job something that
makes other people proud 13 new musicals
a season that's the most in many many
years
you got some stiff competition across
the street you got the 11 handsome
what are you doing this for a better
situation we're in a season in which
everybody has a chance yes and that's
exciting
okay I get that the show is heartwarming
to drop the act yeah we're talking about
the award
why don't we got to do to knock deer of
an Anthony we've actually discussed this
and we feel like we're fine yeah
whatever happened
it really is a beautiful show without a
scintilla of cynicism pretty rare for
this day and age
and yet it's making more than a million
dollars a week I'm Mo Rocca from the
Schoenfeld theater on Broadway on
Broadway makes you want to go see it
before Sunday to see what all the fuss
is about reminder that Kevin Spacey
hosts the 71st annual Tony Awards you
can watch them Sunday night at 8:00 7:00
central
right here on CBS looking forward to
Sunday night Tony night good you'll be
there not performing them